sable
mais
bonjour tout le monde d'abord je suis je
suis très ému et très fier parce que je
suis un pur produit d'el jadida
je suis un gars l'iej 10 10 donc je suis
je suis très très émues d'être là et moi
je vais vous parler d'abord toujours
très émue est toujours heureux
d'entendre mairie bin bin moi je veux
vous parler d'un autre sujet qui me
tient à coeur qui est celui de la santé
de la médecine et de l'évolution cours
des des 25 dernières années parce que ça
fait 25 ans que je suis dans ce domaine
et voir est ce que est ce que vous avez
envie de mourir en bonne santé et il ya
des choses extraordinaires qui se passe
dans la vie je vous montrais j'espère
que ça va marcher
voilà ce qu'a dit de moi ma prof de
biologie en terminale madame soubigou je
sais pas si elle est encore vivante ou
si elle est morte
elle m'a dit que je ne pourrais jamais
faire de biologie dans ma vie et je
pourrai jamais être un médecin 24 ans
plus tard je suis professeur de médecine
je sais pas si elle encore vivante ou si
elle est dans une maison de retraite ça
veut dire que chacun d'entre nous chacun
dans cette salle chacun dans la vie a un
potentiel on sait pas quel type de
potentiel et on ne sait pas à quel
moment on peut avoir ce type de
potentiel mais ce que m'a appris la vie
ce que m'a appris mon métier c'est que
très souvent on a l'impression qu'on a
la connaissance infuser qu'on connaît
toutes les choses sur la génétique la
biologie le cellulaire le vous allez
voir sur des choses assez extraordinaire
je vous posais une question est ce que
vous connaissez la vitesse de la mort
rassurez-vous ce référendum je ne suis
pas dieu mais on a calculé la vitesse de
la mort on sait à quelle vitesse et la
mort et voici la vitesse mes amis de la
mort 2,95 kilomètres par heure
ça veut dire que tous les gens qui ne
bouge pas dans leur vie sont rattrapés
par la mort et si vous n'avez pas envie
de mourir il faut bouger au moins à
quatre kilomètres par heure donc les
gens qui sont assis qui dorment
et qu'il faut pas d'activité physique et
bien aujourd'hui
pourquoi je vous parle de ça parce que
très souvent dans le domaine médical à
chaque fois on dit c'est la cellule
c'est la biologie il faut être les
grands experts mais regardez les
dernières données mondiales 68 % de
l'ensemble des décès qui existe à
travers le monde sont dus à quatre
facteurs de risques qui n'ont rien à
voir avec la biologie ni avec la
génétique ni avec les cellules la
nutrition l'activité physique le tabac
et l'alcool
ça n'a rien à voir avec la génétique ou
la biologie
c'est notre mode de vie et vous allez
voir comment est ce que notre mode de
vie influencent les risques est ce que
nous vivons regardez la probabilité pour
qu'un homme puisse mourir lance qu'il a
une activité saine une vie saine par
rapport à quelqu'un qui n'a pas de vie
saine la différence de pourcentage et
les normes
si vous prenez une vie qui est née
aujourd'hui au japon en norvège en 2016
son espérance de vie elle est de 84 ans
vous prenez une jeune fille qui est née
en sierra leone son espérance de vie de
50 ans il y a trente cinq années
d'espérance de vie d'écart entre le
danemark le japon et le sierra leone au
maroc notre espérance de vie de 75 ans
75 ans 75 73 pour les femmes et 70 pour
les hommes c'est normal les femmes ont
déjà tué les hommes deux ans avant et
c'est pour ça donc non je plaisante pas
dans le contexte marocain mais c'est
pour vous expliquer que nous avons
changé de mode de vie regardez dans
notre pays nous sommes passés d'une
consommation moyenne de 2000 calories à
3000 calories est ce que vous savez quel
est le mois dans lequel nous mangeons le
plus le mois de ramadhan alors là tout
le monde à travers le monde y dit vous
êtes les champions du monde
c'est le pendant le mois de jeûne on
mange le plus c'est à dire mes amis ce
que chez en train de vous dire c'est
notre mode de vie a complètement changé
la façon dont nous mangeons nous faisons
de l'activité physique la façon dont
nous vivons
le stress a changé notre mode de vie est
aujourd'hui les quatre facteurs de
risque dont je vous ai parlé en 2016
aujourd'hui
l' oms elle estime qu'avec ces quatre
facteurs de risque vous diminuez votre
espérance de vie de 9,2 en neuf
véhicules deux ans d'espérance de vie en
moins pour quatre facteurs de risque
nous appelons des facteurs de risque
modifiables
voici comment à travers le monde nous
avons évolué la majorité des maladies
que nous tue aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas
les maladies infectieuses
l'antibiothérapie depuis les années 50 à
régler la majorité des problèmes
aujourd'hui la maladie la main la
majorité des maladies qui nous tue vous
allez voir au maroc ce sont les maladies
chroniques
ce sont les maladies dites de
civilisation et les maladies qui sont
dus au comportement 2,6 voici les
dernières données sur le maroc
ben au maroc c'est pas les maladies
infectieuses qui nous tue c'est
l'hypertension et le diabète c'est les
cancers et les maladies dégénératives
40% de l'ensemble des cancers qui
existent sont dus à une mauvaise
alimentation à une mauvaise hygiène de
vie
évidemment quand on entend parler de ça
dit mais quel sera notre futur
qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
l'évolution de la santé est-ce qu'on
peut un jour mourir en bonne santé si je
puis ainsi m'exprimer et bien beaucoup
de choses ont changé dans les paradoxes
que vous allez voir vous allez constater
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple à travers le
monde il ya plus de gens connectés sur
internet ou sur facebook ou sur les
smartphones que des gens qui sont
connectés à de l'eau potable ou un
réseau d'assainissement beaucoup plus
regardées 3,2 milliards d'internautes et
regardez combien de personnes sont
connectées à de l'eau potable et donc
des risques donc de maladie
regardez également les changements
climatiques notre pays a accueilli
récemment la coop 22 mai regardez en
nous aurons deux cent cinquante mille
décès supplémentaires de la manière dont
nous gérons notre environnement
ça n'a rien à voir avec la biologie ça
n'a rien à voir avec la génétique ça n'a
rien à voir avec madame soubigou qui me
disait que monsieur lesquels vous serez
jamais un médecin vous serez jamais ça
un biologiste ça a à voir avec la façon
dont nous gérons notre mode de vie
regarder des chiffres très intéressants
en 1850
30% de l'énergie que nous produisions à
travers le monde
elle était d'origine humaine c'était
notre activité regardez en 2016 0 7% de
la production est de nature humaine elle
robotisée etc
nous ne pratiquons plus d'activité
physique je poserais pas de question
dans cette salle combien parmi vous
pratiquez une activité physique
régulière cinq heures par semaine si je
vous posais la question je vais pleurer
et donc je vais pas vous poser la
question parce que normalement l' oms
indique si vous voulez rester en bonne
santé il faudrait faire cinq heures
d'exercice par semaine et je ne suis pas
sûr que la majorité d'entre eux
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer dans le
futur mes amis ce qui va se passer c'est
que de plus en plus nous allons
manipuler les jeunes vous le savez
qu'aujourd'hui en 2016 on est capable de
connaître votre carte génétique on est
capable de savoir aujourd'hui exactement
comment vous êtes mais si on manipule et
j'aime ce qu'on va faire ce qu'on va
avoir des délits qui sont blonds aux
yeux bleus intelligent et performant on
est déjà intelligent et performants nous
les deux colis n'est ce pas mais si on
manipule la génétique et bien voilà ce
qui va se passer
voilà ce qu'est ce qu'on est capable de
faire en 2016 on est capable de vous
scannez et de connaître exactement en
trois dimensions vos cellules on est
capable de le faire en 2016 vous savez
qu'en 2016 on est capable d'opérer à
5000 km de distance par un robot on n'a
pas besoin que le chirurgien soit
présent si on continue comme ça c'est ce
qu'on peut avoir une espérance de vie à
milan encore une fois on dira mais
attention ce que maintenant la dame on
n'en est pas là et bien si on continue
comme ça c'est la manipuler génie
génétique qui peut permettre de faire
vivre des cellules parce qu'aujourd'hui
on est capable de fabriquer des cellules
pas des cellules humaines dont l'un
capable de fabriquer donc des cellules
voilà notre révolution voici notre
révolution
ça n'a rien à voir avec la génétique je
vous rappelle que le diabète l'obésité
en sur le plan génétique c'est que 18%
des cas mais 82% sont liés à notre mode
de vie nous allons être capables de
fabriquer des médicaments qui seront en
même temps des aliments des médicaments
de nous faire vivre
sans aucun problème on est capable de
faire dans vingt ans dans 25 ans est de
faire en sorte que vous restiez en bonne
santé et d'avoir de la manipulation
génétique et de choisir si on veut avoir
des garçons des filles des blonds des
intelligents des coefficient
intellectuel à 143 150 on est capable de
le faire aujourd'hui en 2016 mais mais
est-ce que ça ça va conduire fait que la
santé deviendra un luxe
est ce que pour être en bonne santé
est-ce que la santé que nous voulons ça
doit être une santé qui coûte très cher
et regarder une couverture du time qui
était très intéressant puis je voulais
partager avec vous elle dit c'est pas la
maladie qui va nous tuer c'est sa
facture plus on va aller loin dans la
manipulation est dans le fait de vouloir
aller dans une santé incroyable plus ça
va nous coûter cher
je voudrais vous montrer ça pour eux de
redescendre dans la réalité dans la
réalité de la vie de tous les jours dans
la réalité marocaine
la santé n'a pas de prix mais elle a un
coût
nous en tant que société quel est le
coût que nous sommes prêts à payer une
bonne hygiène de vie un bon mode de vie
ou de la manipulation génétique ou la
manipulation cellulaire
qu'est ce qu'on veut vraiment et qu'est
ce qu'on est prêt à payer et je termine
en disant c'est fabuleux un les
américains avant vous montrez à
génétique je vous ai montré la
manipulation génétique mais regardez la
publication de la plus grande revue
scientifique médicale chez américain
qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle dit il n'y a
aucun médicament actuel au potentiel
meyer qui va exister que le maintien en
bonne santé d'un programme d'activité
physique c'est à dire ils ont fait le
tour on a fait le tour de pub père de la
science de la génétique de la biologie
de la cellule et on se retrouve à dire
que le meilleur médicament
c'est un programme d'exercices physiques
à vie mais nous comme on fait jamais les
choses comme tout le monde au maroc
par quoi je termine par le gem d'oullins
voilà s'il faut mourir
ah ben on va mourir avec un bon couscous
de cali je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]